you have kind of like on on social media
you have a very kind of in-your-face
attitude which is perfect for social
media that gets you 20 million followers
because you're putting it all out there
you know you're putting your whole life
out there pretty much I mean there's a
lot of people that don't put their life
out there that have more I know me but
can't that [ __ ] up your acting career if
people get to know you too much but then
I worry that it's like if you if you if
you read this book I read it and you
don't like me after reading this book
then you're not gonna like my acting
you're not gonna like me in the movie
you're not because this is literally who
I am well here's the thing with this
book I read me Bella's new book is
called the life of a wannabe mogul a
mental disarray which is available today
wherever books are sold
now I'll tell you why I respond to this
book see I like to look I don't I like
to look into people's lives to me what
you've done here is you took your
journal all your inner thoughts and you
wrote them down and I always want to
yeah I always want to open up somebody's
journal and see what the [ __ ] is really
you've opened up your journal here